former Secretary of State Condoleezza
Rice was appointed national security
advisor by president george w bush in
2001 four years later she became the
first female african-american secretary
of state while in office she championed
an initiative called transformational
diplomacy it was intended to expand and
strengthen democratic institutions
worldwide rice drew from personal
experiences in her new book democracy
stories from the long road to freedom it
examines how democracies are fostered
and sometimes fail
she writes there is no more thrilling
moment than when people finally seize
their rights and their Liberty that
moment is necessary right and inevitable
it is also terrifying and disruptive and
chaotic and what follows it is hard
really really hard Condoleezza Rice
joins us now at this table good morning
good morning
I remember speech you made in Cairo and
what you basically said for 60 years my
country the United States pursued
stability at the expense of democracy in
this region here in the Middle East and
we achieved neither now we're taking a
different course we're supporting the
Democratic aspirations of all people yes
it's important to do so so how we doing
you're telling us stories in it yes well
as this with anything that's worth doing
it's hard and the jury's out for a very
long time but we've seen some successes
and we've seen some reverses and one of
the things that I wanted to do with this
book is to challenge those who keep
saying that democracy is in recession or
democracy is going backwards to remember
that this is a very long road and there
will be setbacks but for every turkey
with erawan or every Egypt where the
Arab Spring has given way to a military
coup you have a Colombia which has has
rescued itself from a failed state in
the early 2000s with American help you
have a Kenya that despite contested
elections continues along a more or less
democratic path and I wanted to remind
people also that our own history is one
of a very very long road to freedom an
American Constitution where my ancestors
were once counted as three
it's a man where my father couldn't vote
reliably in 1952 in Birmingham Alabama
and now we've had a black president
I've been Secretary of State Colin
Powell has been Secretary of State we
sometimes lose we lose sight of the big
picture you called slavery America's
birth defect which i think is a very
poetic way to describe I've never heard
it described that way well a birth
defect is something that is always with
you but it's always something also
something that you can overcome I think
in this case we see that this birth
defect of slavery colors the way that we
look at each other we are not a
colorblind society we probably never
will be
sometimes it causes us to look at each
other with suspicion and that's at the
root of any number of problems including
issues of policing that we've been
concerned with and so I like to describe
it in that way but I like to remind
people that every day we get up and we
try to make this imperfect democracy a
little bit better we try to include more
people in We the People and that's
America's story let me ask you this book
though you write Americans seem to be
experiencing a kind of crisis of
confidence about our own democracy who
we are and what we value yeah that is
true under President Trump well it's
been true for some time we've seen these
these polls for a long time that
Americans are losing confidence in the
institutions and that no institution in
America today is really fully trusted
and since as I write in this book
democracy is always at that knife's edge
between chaos and authoritarianism
democracy is the sweet spot where we
channel our concerns our our wants our
desires through institutions if you're
in favor democracy what do you as a
nation do for the aspirations of people
in other countries well the question yes
and it raises questions of sovereignty
and other issues
well sovereignty should never be a
defense or tyranny and for mistreating
your people I think first of all you pay
attention to us here I'm a big believer
that America has to be strong at home
America
have to feel confident but we have
learned I think the hard way that when
we don't champion the rights of people
bad things happen so no one is unhappy
that these days that Germany and Japan
wants states that challenge their
neighbors that were violent in their
regions are now democracies and our
pillars of the International people are
unhappy about Egypt for example
yes but Egypt under Mubarak one of the
things we want to do charlie is we want
to make sure that when we have friends
and allies of course we're going to have
to talk to the Egyptian president but
just think had Mubarak reformed maybe
there wouldn't have been a revolution
condi you write in your book about
meeting Vladimir Putin for the first
time you even say that you felt sorry
for him well I felt bad because I met
him in in 1992 he was deputy mayor of
st. Petersburg he was standing at this
very fancy party and he was there in a
kind of Soviet era that's all alone in a
great a pale short well I was pale and
sore but boy does he have piercing eyes
I will tell you that and now you see him
as what is there any doubt in your mind
about the role that Vladimir Putin has
played in our country I see him as an
authoritarian with an assertive and
aggressive foreign policy I see him as
somebody who is engaged in trying to
subvert democracy in a number of
countries and I do see him as someone
who undoubtedly interfered in our
election but he's an eye-for-an-eye kind
of guy
in 2012 we said his election was
fraudulent he's trying to say to us let
me show you that yours can be too and we
have to be careful we should investigate
I'm furious at the Russians for what
they've done but let's not give him the
satisfaction of thinking that he has
caused Americans to doubt the legitimacy
of our own democratic processes that
would help him to win Condoleezza Rice
thank you and her book democracy stories
from the long road to freedom goes on
sale tomorrow